(mouse clicking)
(jingly beeping)
(bright music)
- Increasing evidence suggests
that normal brain development
is impaired in schizophrenia
and other neuropsychiatric
disorders long before
the onset of symptoms.
So emerging genetics and
other data intriguingly
have been implicating immune molecules
and immune related pathways,
raising many questions about
the underlying biology.
So we recently discovered
an unexpected role
for our resident immune
cell called microglia
in this sculpting process,
this pruning process.
And so today I'd like to tell
you about what we've learned
about how it is that these cells
know which synapse to prune
and which synapses perhaps not to prune
and how our work using
mouse models are providing
new biological insight
into this pruning pathway
and how this might go
awry in schizophrenia
and other neurodevelopmental disorders.
Neural circuits undergo tremendous
remodeling during development.
We start out with an excess
of synaptic connections
that are maintained in the mature brain
and through a developmental process
called pruning or synapse elimination.
Many of these extra synaptic
connections are permanently
removed while others get
strengthened and maintained.
This concept of use it or lose it.
So this process is of course regulated by
and modulated by experience
and this process,
refinement process, is
necessary for developmental
and the precise wiring
of synapses in the brain.
And disruptions in the process of pruning
are thought to underlie neurodevelopmental
and neuropsychiatric disorders.
Now interestingly, there are
different critical periods
of pruning that happen in
different parts of the brain,
and as you heard earlier
today, interestingly,
parts of the brain like frontal cortex
are the last area of the brains to prune.
So the big question of course is what
regulates this pruning process?
So a major question in the field,
and one that my lab has been
intensely interested in,
is understanding how it
is that specific synapses
are eliminated during development.
If we can understand
the mechanisms by which
specific synapses get
pruned, or vulnerable,
this might provide new insight,
and even therapeutic insight,
into how these synapses
get lost in disease.
So it's well established,
as you've heard today,
that neuronal activity
plays a critical role
in refining synapses and
synaptic connections.
So we know for example
that activity sets up
a local competition, so if
you look at this cartoon here,
you can see this neuron
is innervated by inputs,
these left and right eye inputs,
if you were to for example,
label these inputs with a visual system.
But over the course of development,
you can see that this neuron,
that some of these inputs,
in this case the blue ones,
get permanently removed
while the red ones get
strengthened and maintained.
So what is the question mark that
we're interested in is
understanding what are the molecules
that link change in activity,
that with a physical elimination of
the blue input but not the red one.
So much of the field of course
is focused on the neurons themselves,
these are in fact cells that get pruned.
But emerging evidence implicate glia,
the non neuronal cells of the
brain in this pruning process.
And more recent work have been
implicating these cells called microglia.
Now as a card carrying glial biologist,
I have to say I've ignored
these cells my entire career
until very recently and
that is in part because
these are the only cells
not born in the brain.
These are our immune cells, they actually,
now we know reside and are originating
from the yolk sac and they
actually enter the brain
very, very early in development,
in fact in a mouse they enter the brain
as early as embryonic date eight.
That means they're the first
non-neuronal cell in the brain,
they're there when an
amazing growth is happening
in the embryonic brain yet
we know surprisingly little
about the normal roles of these cells.
Much of what we knew about them
was in the context of injury and disease.
Now these cells make up about
10% of the cells of the brain,
they tile the brain, but one
of the things that makes them
incredibly unique and
different from any other cell,
is they're our resident phagocytes,
they're actually by
nature of the fact that
they're immune cells, they're
really good at eating things,
or phagocytosing things,
but the other thing
that two photon in vivo
imaging has shown us,
meaning if you were to put a
microscope over a mouse's brain
and thin their skull
and use a reporter line
in which all the microglia
are labeled green,
what you can see is that these
cells are incredibly dynamic.
You can see the processes are
constantly moving all the time
and they're serving the
extracellular environment.
And the big question we wanted to know
is what is it that they're surveying?
And one of the things we now appreciate
that they're serving are synapses,
so if you were to for
example overlay neurons,
in this case this neuron
is labeled in red.
You can see the processes
of these microglia
intimately contacting spines
and axons all the time.
This is happening in your
brain right now, it's amazing.
And one of the things we also appreciate
from our work and others
is that they can even
sense local changes in neuronal activity.
So if you manipulate that
neuron, you fire it more,
or if you silence it, the
microglia knows somehow,
and that suggests that there
must be some sort of signals
that are being transmitted
and that the microglia
have receptors that
recognize those signals.
So what about the post-natal brain
when all of this remarkable
plasticity is happening?
What about early in development?
So that is the question
we set up to address
a number of years ago and we use
the developing mouse
visual system as our model
because so much was known
about how synapses prune
in this particular part of the brain.
And so we use the developing
retina geniculate system
of the mouse where you can
actually label the inputs
from the two eyes with
dye and then we could ask
what are the microglia
doing at that circuit
during the critical period of pruning?
And what you can see here is
that the microglia in green
are intimately associated with
the left and right eye axons
and the question that Dori
Schafer in my lab has asked
was are they actually engulfing
or eating those synapses?
And what we found is that
almost every microglia
we surveyed during this peak
of remodeling at this point
were full of inputs from
the left and the right eye,
they were actually in their lysosomes,
and quite importantly
this process of pruning
was developmentally regulated.
They were doing it during
these critical periods
of pruning but not later and that suggests
that there must be some
signals that tell the microglia
to do this and other signals
that tell the microglia to stop
and we're very much interested in
understanding what those signals are.
So the next big question
of course is how is it
that microglia know
which synapse to prune?
Now we now appreciate that
it's not a random process.
The first hypothesis was
well, they're phagocytes,
they just happen to be there,
anything that's around, they're gonna eat,
but we knew there were
critical periods, again.
And so that suggested the possibility
that they were recognizing
synapses through some molecules.
So going back to that activity
dependent competition model,
the red and the green, the
red and the blue inputs,
if you change activity, we
know that the less active
inputs are selectively eliminated
or more preferentially eliminated.
And again using the visual
system we can manipulate activity
in the two eyes and
block activity in one eye
with a drug that blocks sodium
dependent action potentials
and what we've found is that
microglia preferentially
engulf the axons from the less active eye,
and that again tells us this
has some activity dependent cues.
So how do microglia know
which synapse to prune?
Well recent work, if you go back to work
I did as a post doc in Ben Barres's lab,
back then we unexpectedly
identified a role for a group
of immune molecules called
complement in this process
of synaptic pruning, in
the mouse visual system.
Now this is a group of immune molecules
traditionally associated with
the innate immune system.
And this was a surprising
finding at the time
but what we essentially found
is that the retinal ganglion cells,
the cells that are
actually getting pruned,
are actually expressing some
of these molecules like C1q
and if you knock out
C1q and downstream C3,
these mice failed to segregate into
their eye specific
territories and they remain
multiply innervated, even into adulthood.
And so this raises question
of how is it that a group
of secreted molecules that are related
with the immune system could be doing
something as precise as pruning?
Well going back to the immune system,
this is where we learned a lot,
complement's main role
in the immune system
is to tag apoptotic cells and
bacteria for rapid removal.
So for example C1q would
bind to that bacterial cell,
this would set up a proteolytic
cascade that then cleaves
downstream components like C4, C2, C3,
and the canonical way by which
that cell would get removed
is it would get tagged
by C3 and then a main way
it gets removed is through
phagocytes like macrophages
in your periphery that express
receptors for complement.
And what we found is that
complement was actually tagging,
if you will, subsets of
synapses during development
and that microglia are the
main cells that express
this complement receptor and
that led to this hypothesis
that microglia were recognizing
complement tagged synapses,
maybe the less active synapses.
And indeed when we knocked
out either the receptor
on the microglia or complement itself,
microglia are only about half
as good as engulfing synapses
so this identifies complement
as one of the main ways
by which these synapses get pruned.
But of course it also tells
you it's not the whole story.
Now importantly if you fail
to prune for this mechanism,
this led to sustained defects
in synaptic connectivity,
there were too many synapses,
in fact David Prince's lab later went on
in the C1q knockout mice to
show that these mice remain
multiply innervated and
hyperconnected and they were
more prone to epilepsy, at
least to the adolescent period.
And that of course raises
questions many questions
we're actively investigating
relating to the functional
and behavioral consequences
of not enough pruning
or too much pruning during development.
And that now brings me to
this question that this is one
of many mechanisms by
which synapses gets pruned,
is unexpected because it
involves an immune cell
and a group of these
secreted immune molecules,
but there's many other
lines of evidence now
that are implicating both glia
and other immune molecules
like the MHC and the PRB.
Now importantly, must
like the immune system,
this pruning pathway we've identified
seems to be tightly regulated.
Microglia do not continue
to do this through life,
there are times and places
in which this is happening,
they become less phagocytic
as the animal matures,
and a lot of these molecules
like C3 are dramatically
downregulated in the healthy brain.
You'd not want to have pruning
continuing all the time,
but what if it did,
what if it kept pruning?
Or what if the brakes weren't there?
Or what if something turned
this pathway on too much?
We hypothesize that this
could lead to an excess
or an inappropriate pruning
of the wrong synapse
or too many synapses and
this could potentially
lead to some of the
pathobiology underlying
neurodevelopmental or neuropsychiatric
disorders such as schizophrenia.
So this has been the question
that we've been interested
for a very long time but
of course as you know,
there are not very many good
animal models of schizophrenia,
so it's been a very
hard question to tackle.
Now indeed several lines
of evidence suggest
that synaptic pruning may
be altered in schizophrenia.
In fact the pruning hypothesis
put forth by Feinberg
40 years ago proposed an
altered cortical pruning
is critical development of the disease.
And indeed this classic
study by David Lewis's lab
shows very intriguingly a loss
of spines in the prefrontal
cortex of some individuals
with schizophrenia.
And imaging studies have
also showed cortical thinning
in patients even before
the onset of symptoms.
And putting this together,
the pruning hypothesis
is pretty attractive, however,
it's not actually been
directly demonstrated.
We don't yet know, for
example, in these patients,
were these really a pruning defect?
Were these lost or never formed?
Was this cause or consequence?
And again, this is very difficult
to really tackle in models
because there really aren't
any good animal models.
Well this of course is
where human genetics
can be extremely useful
and in the next few slides
I'd like to share with you
new and recently published
findings by colleagues Steve McCarroll
and his graduate student Aswin Sekar,
who have been using genetics
to identify mechanisms
and novel pathways for treatments.
Now the strongest genetic signal
by far has been on chromosome 6,
in a region known as the MHC locus,
which contains many genes,
many of which relate to the immune system.
But researchers had no idea
which of these many
genes contribute to risk.
Now this region spans hundreds of genes,
many of them, as I said
encode immune related genes,
but the MHC signal has
really remained unexplained.
And really it doesn't follow
any mathematical or statistical
patterns explainable by any
one known genetic variant,
so what could be explaining this effect?
Well intriguingly and
interestingly, within the MHC,
one of the strongest risks
are associated with loci
near the gene C4, complement C4,
which of course is a key part
of the complement cascade
I talked to you about earlier.
Now Aswin honed in on this
for that and other reasons
and he was also, and Steve's
lab has been interested
in this question of
structural variability,
why different people have
different numbers and copies
of different genes and
they developed methods,
molecular techniques, to characterize
the C4 gene's structure
in human DNA samples.
And quite interesting, what
you'll see is there are
actually two C4 genes, C4A and C4B,
and unlike most genes,
this gene has a high degree
of structural variability and variation.
And what he found is that
some people's genomes have
extra copies of A, some have
extra copies of B, some have,
completely lack one or the other,
and this led Aswin to
ask could the structural
form of C4 you inherit,
could this be related
to the increased risk of schizophrenia?
Now the challenge was that
although the Aswins developed
these to measure C4A
and B and the variation
in different individuals, how do you get,
how do you link this to
schizophrenia risk, right?
So Aswin's team developed
a novel way to map
how C4 structure relates to SNPs, right,
or which genetic data
was already available
from tens of thousands of individuals.
They essentially built a map
to infer the four most common
forms of C4 from the SNP
data, surrounding the gene,
which essentially created
molecular barcodes
from the SNP patterns and it works
because humans share long genomic segments
they have inherited from common ancestors,
and this map can allow
them to take advantage
of SNP data and giant
databases from around the world
which essentially turned a
molecular biology problem
into a big data problem,
and here's what they found.
Alleles of C4 appear to shape risk
in proportion to their
effect on C4A expression.
On the left, which you'll
see, is how each alleles,
here, relates to schizophrenia risk,
and you can see those that have more C4A
have a significantly increased risk.
On the right is each allele's
effect on C4A expression
in the brain, they found
the C4 gene's structure
could predict C4 gene activity.
And notice now that those that have C4A
have more C4A expression, and together,
I know I'm oversimplifying this story
which has been recently
published earlier this year,
but for now the important thing to realize
is the more C4 you make from the locus,
the greater the risk of schizophrenia.
Now that raises a number of questions
that we're now actively investigating,
and we started to collaborate
Steve's lab with my lab
and also Michael Carroll's
lab to ask this question,
how is that elevated C4A,
how does this contribute
to the risk of schizophrenia,
what is the biology
underlying this risk factor?
Now this brought together my lab
which has been studying
complement and pruning,
Michael Carroll's lab is an immunologist
who's been studying C4 for his career
and all of our labs together joined forces
in this multidisciplinary collaboration.
And the first thing we did is
we looked at the C4 protein,
and they're actually pretty
good human antibodies for this,
and we basically asked, much
like we'd noticed in the mouse,
could C4 be tagging synapses
in the brain of humans?
And we used tissue that was
generated and given to us
by the Stanley Collection
and we looked in these brains
and showed that C4 was in fact binding
to subsets of synapses in the human brain
in the schizophrenia patients.
And then moreover, Heather de Rivera
in Steve McCarroll's lab
grew cortical neurons
and then stained them after they developed
with C4 antibodies and
shown that C4 also binds
to these synaptic structures
in cortical neurons.
And interestingly and importantly,
C4 is actually being made by the neurons
and secreted by these human neurons.
So this is just early data to suggest
that the protein is there
and it's actually binding
the synapses, at least
under these conditions.
But of course the big question
is, is it related to pruning?
So this is when again went back to mouse,
so we went from human to mouse
in this case and we asked
does C4 mediate synaptic pruning?
And so we went back to our
very classic retina geniculate system,
we used mice that were
generated by Mike Carroll's lab,
these C4 knockout mice and Allison Bialas,
who was a graduate student with me
and now a post doc with
Mike, did this experiment,
basically did the eye-specific segregation
or pruning experiments in
C4 mice versus control.
And the prediction
would be that lacking C4
would lead to a defect
or a lack of pruning,
much like we saw in the C1q and C3 mice,
and that's exactly what we saw.
And interestingly the
retinal ganglion cells
were expressing a lot of C4
during the peak of pruning,
so this is a pre-synaptic neuron,
and mice that lacked C4
failed to segregate nicely
into these eye-specific territories,
which you can actually label
by tracing the left and right
eye with chlorotoxin and
then doing this threshold
then to show the two eye interactions.
So this told us that lacking
C4 led to failure to prune,
but the big question now moving forward
is could excessive pruning contribute
to the pathobiology of schizophrenia?
Could this relate to David Lewis's study,
and so that is actually
what we're now together,
as a collaboration,
actively investigating.
Could over-activation of complement during
this critical periods of pruning
contribute to wiring
defects in schizophrenia?
A number of other
questions were raised that
we're actively pursuing as
well and one of the questions
that again stemmed from the beautiful work
presented earlier today,
could pruning also help us
to understanding age of
onset of schizophrenia?
Might pruning become too intense
or prolonged in certain individuals?
Might it expose other,
pre-existing vulnerabilities?
And how is it that
environment, like stress,
impinges on the genetic pathways like C4?
And we're also learning to now
move from the visual system
that we love so much into much
more uncharted territories,
which is the prefrontal
cortex and Mike Carroll
is developing mice models
to look at overexpression
of multiple copies of human
C4A in mice so that we can
start to address some of these questions.
Now I'm just gonna end in
my last slide to try to
pull this together, but also
to broaden this a bit more.
The idea that although
we've been focused on
neurodevelopmental and
neuropsychiatric disorders,
could this pruning pathway represent
a more general, common pathway
that not only might explain
synapse loss during development,
but actually could it actually
also help to understand
why synapses are vulnerable
in the adult brain,
especially in aging and
neurodegenerative disease
such as Alzheimer's?
And so indeed multiple
work now from several labs
including our own has suggested
that this very same pruning
pathway that I just told you about
becomes aberrantly
activated, very, very early
in Alzheimer's Disease
models and other models,
and that indeed, that this
overactivation contributes
to synapse loss and very excitingly,
if you block this pathway,
either genetically,
or with antibodies or other mechanisms,
you can prevent synapse
loss and in some cases,
even some of the cognitive impairment.
And so I'll end with this
positive, hopeful last slide
that suggests that maybe
by understanding detailed
mechanisms by which
complement and microglia
are selectively targeting
synapses in these various models,
could this help us to try
to identify new targets
to particularly manipulate synapse loss
in the right time and the right place?
And could it also identify new
biomarkers for some of these disorders?
So I'll just end there by
thanking a lot of individuals,
past and present lab members,
incredible collaborators,
and of course generous funding.
Thanks so much.
(audience applauding)
- So we're talking
about brain development.
And as you know there are many
ways this can get screwed up.
It can get screwed up by heredity,
as you'll hear about
from Matt State later.
It can get screwed up by disease
or environmental deprivation.
And so a convenient way
of conceptualizing this
is that imagine that we have
a number of different measures
of brain maturation in
different parts of the brain,
and so on, different processes.
But all these processes improve with age.
And in the case of
developmental brain disorder,
it's a derailment and you see
a accumulated deficit
as the person matures.
And the question that we're
really interested in now
is whether at the time of diagnosis,
which often is in early childhood
in many of these diseases or even later,
can we initiate a
treatment that can reverse
the consequence of the disease?
So we can imagine conceptually
three potential outcomes.
And the most dismal outcome
is the one illustrated
on the top and that is is
that I can only intervene
in a very early, critical period,
and then if you miss that period,
maybe the damage has
already been done in utero,
prior to birth, it's just too
late to initiate a treatment.
So that's the most
pessimistic point of view.
The most optimistic point
of view is that indeed
we can apply our great
knowledge of neurobiology
to come up with good
treatments and they actually
reverse the course of the disease
and actually restore normal function.
And probably a realistic possibility
is the one in the middle,
the hopeful scenario,
that we can initiate treatments
that may prevent further decline.
So the work in my lab is
addressing these questions
in different ways and one
of the ways we look at
is a genetically defined
disease called fragile X,
we've done a lot of work on that.
But we're also interested
in the consequences
of environmental deprivation,
particularly a disease called
amblyopia, and I'm gonna tell
you about that work today.
So amblyopia is a not
uncommon visual disability.
It affects approximately
3% of the world population,
and it's more prevalent in nations
where there's poor early
childhood pediatric screening.
Is this a consequence
of poor quality vision
during infancy and early childhood,
and that poor quality could arise
because the eyes aren't properly aligned
at birth so the child is seeing double,
can arise 'cause there's a
dense cataract in one eye
or a droopy eyelid, or
it could arise because
there are different refractive
indices in the two eyes,
so you can't focus an image
on both eyes at the same time.
The consequence is the
same and it is usually
a fairly severe visual
impairment in one of the eyes.
Now if that optical
abnormality or what have you
is corrected very early in life,
there is a good chance to see
some recovery of function.
But if that correction occurs later,
there's a very dismal prognosis.
So luckily there are animal
models for this amblyopia,
in fact every mammal with binocular vision
will show a susceptibility to poor quality
visual experience during early life.
I'm gonna show you a cat
video, it's always popular,
(audience laughing)
to illustrate the visual
disability in a kitten.
So what we're looking at is,
that's the top of the kitten's head,
and this kitten had been
deprived of normal vision
through one eye for only seven days,
about the fourth post-natal week,
and then that eye was unpatched,
and now we're gonna
measure the consequences.
And first we're gonna measure
the vision to the good eye
and the way we do this, when I say we,
I'm being very liberal,
this is actually work
done by Donald Mitchell,
a collaborator of mine
at Dalhousie University,
and Don's been studying
this for many, many years.
And he puts the animal
in a box on a jackstand
and the animal learns to
jump down onto a placard
with the vertical stripes,
so the animal's reporting
whether he can resolve
the stripes by choosing
the correct placard to
jump on, and he gets a pat
on the back and a little
bit of kitten food,
and they're very happy
to perform this task.
So first we're gonna look at
a kitten performing a task
through the good eye, the eye
that had not been deprived,
and you can see they're
quite keep to do this,
they jump down, they
find the right stripes.
Get a little liverwurst.
And they could make the
stripes closer and closer
to get a measure of visual acuity,
so this is a way that they can determine
how well the animal can
resolve visual stimuli,
the same way you would at the eye doctor.
So now this is the same
animal but now we're gonna do
this test through the eye that had only
temporarily been deprived of
vision, only for seven days.
And what you're gonna see
is there's a very severe
visual impairment, so the
good eye's being occluded
with a black contact lens,
so the kitten's forced
to look through its
lazy eye and you can see
that it's having great
difficulty in even seeing
the stripes versus the
empty chamber there.
So it's a significant visual
disability and as I said,
this is a kind of disability that affects
up to 3% of the human population.
The visual disability will
persist even when the eye's been
reopened and the animal's
allowed to see through both eyes.
And this is shown in this graph,
where this is now a plot
of the visual acuity,
the ability of the animal
to resolve the stripes,
as a function of time after
the eye has been opened,
the bad eye has been opened.
And the green symbols show vision through
the non-deprived eye and the blue symbols
show the vision through the deprived eye.
So you can see that
although there is some,
a slight recovery, there's not much,
and there's actually fairly
severe visual disability
compared to the vision
through the good eye.
So this model of temporary
monocular deprivation
has been around for over 50 years,
and many others, probably
many hundreds others,
of other scientists
have been studying this
very intensively, and we've
actually learned quite a bit
about the mechanisms that
serve this disruption
in the cortex and yet our work
has had very little impact
on how the clinical
management of amblyopia.
So the question I want to address today is
can the understanding of the
synaptic basis for amblyopia
suggest novel treatments
to promote recovery,
that are better than
current standard of care?
And the simple answer
to that question is yes.
Here it is.
So these are kittens that were
visually impaired in one eye,
stable visual disability,
and a treatment was initiated
based on principles of synaptic
plasticity at this age.
This is now two months
after the deprived eye
had been opened so about
three months of age.
You can see that there's
a very rapid recovery
of vision through the deprived eye.
So essentially curing this
form of visual disability.
So hopefully I've gotten your attention
with this amazing result and
now I'm gonna unpack it for you
and tell you what that
magical treatment was.
But to do so I need to walk you
through a little bit of background
which is the visual system
of mammals with two eyes,
often kittens and mice or monkeys.
And the visual pathway
originates with these
retinal ganglion cells and the two eyes,
they project centrally,
they relay in the lateral
geniculate nucleus, your LGN,
and then they go on and synapse
on neurons in primary visual cortex.
So when visual experience
is normal to the two eyes,
as connections mature and
we have binocular vision.
When there's an imbalance
in vision to the two eyes,
it sets in motion a
stereotype choreography
of synaptic changes were the
inputs carrying information
from the deprived eye are weakened
and the inputs carrying
information by the open eye
are eventually, show a
propensity towards strengthening.
So we can measure these
consequences of that anatomical
plasticity functionally as well,
so we can put a microelectrode
in primary visual cortex,
and we can record the
activity that's evoked
by stimulation of the
right eye or the left eye.
So that's, I just direct your attention
to these histograms in the top.
So this is now the number
of nerve impulses triggered
in a response to
stimulation of the right eye
and the left eye prior to any deprivation.
So you can see this is
a neuron that responds
happily to stimulation of both eyes,
in fact there's a slight ocular dominance,
slight preference for
stimulation of the right eye.
And now this right eyelid is closed
and then the neuron is
recorded again later.
What you can see is it's
essentially lost all responsiveness
to stimulation of the eye
that had been deprived.
So no wonder the kittens can't see,
we've disconnected the
cortex from that eye.
So I mentioned that it
is possible to correct
these visual disabilities if
you intervene early enough.
And the current standard
of care is a therapy
called patching therapy and
essentially that comprises
putting a patch, usually an opaque patch,
over the strong eye to force
the weak eye to function.
And that can be successful, so
when you patch the strong eye
you get a recovery of
vision to the weak eye.
Now there are a number of
limitations of this approach,
not least of which is
compliance because children
don't like to have these eye patches.
But also there is the
gains in the amblyopic eye
often come at the expense of the good eye,
'cause you're now patching it.
There's little improvement
in binocular vision,
so no stereopsis, and
again, it's only effective
if you initiate this treatment
prior to age eight or so.
So what are we, let's get under the hood
and see what happens
during reverse patching.
Well, it's again we're recording
now from a single neuron
in primary visual cortex,
this is the situation,
we're gonna start with the
situation after a period
of monocular deprivation
so we have a neuron here
that's responding only to the left eye,
there's no response to the right eye,
that's because we've already performed
an ocular deprivation so
the kitten is amblyopic.
Now what we're gonna do is we're
gonna patch the strong eye,
we're gonna open the weak
eye and see what happens.
And what happens is that
initially you get a loss
of responsiveness to
the newly deprived eye,
but with time you start
to gain a responsiveness
in the formerly deprived, now seeing eye.
So this is good, we can get a
recovery, but it's not ideal,
it's not ideal because it
actually is a zero sum game.
So the gains that we're
getting in this weak, lazy eye
are coming at the expense
of the strong eye.
And as in the case of
patching therapy in humans,
this reverse patching in the animal models
also shares a sensitive period,
so this is a classic
study done by Blakemore
and Van Sluyters in cats showing
that the ability to reverse
this ocular dominance shift
or this change in physiology
in the cortex diminishes greatly with age
so that by eight weeks of age,
it's very difficult to get a reversal,
and it's essentially gone
by 12 to 14 weeks of age.
This same sort of pattern is seen
in any species that's been looked at.
So there are problems
with patching therapy
but these limitations not withstanding,
they do demonstrate that we
can rejuvenate weak synapses,
we can rejuvenate these
inputs that previously
were incapable of provoking a response.
So what we'd like to do
is understand that process
a little bit better so
that maybe we can devise
a better way to restore function.
So to understand where we're gonna go,
I have to introduce some of
the simple principles
of synaptic plasticity.
So the excitatory synapses in our brains
use glutamate as a neurotransmitter,
glutamate activates two
types of post-synaptic
glutamate receptor,
glutamate gated ion channels.
The AMPA receptor mediates
fast synaptic transmission,
and the NMDA receptor
is an important trigger
for modification of synaptic strength.
And so what we've learned
over 30 or 40 years
of intensive effort is
that we can indeed modify
the strength of synaptic transmission
and we do so by activating NMDA receptors.
So strong activation of NMDA receptors
will make a synapse stronger,
and that's a phenomenon
they call long term potentiation or LTP.
Modest activation of NMDA
receptors leads to the reversed
form of plasticity called
long term depression or LTD.
And the NMDA receptor
has an unusual property,
it's actually very sensitive
to how well correlated
pre and post-snyaptic neurons are,
so it's strongly correlated activity,
strongly activates NMDA receptors,
and you're more likely to
get a synaptic strengthening.
So this is one fundamental feature
of what we call bidirectional
synaptic plasticity.
Another fundamental feature
is that that learning rule
actually is also modifiable
so if neurons are quieted
for a long period of time,
there's a shift in this function.
So for example the function
will shift to the left,
if we put animals in
the dark, for instance,
this function will shift to
the left in visual cortex
which has the net effect
of making the potentiation
more readily observed and making
depression more difficult.
So we call that property metaplasticity,
it's a type of homeostatic
plasticity to make sure
the network of synapses
keeps within a dynamic range.
So now how are we gonna explain
this effect of reverse patching?
So let's go through this again.
We have a situation where
we have a neuron response
only to stimulation of one eye.
This eye has been
functionally disconnected,
and now we're going to
close that strong eye
and the first thing that happens
is that the neuron stops,
loses responsiveness to
the newly deprived eye.
So this is believed to be a consequence
of these mechanisms of long
term depression, in fact,
there's very, very good evidence
to support that statement,
so this initial loss of
responsiveness is due to a demotion
of the strength of excitatory
synaptic transmission
from inputs carrying
information to that eye.
But something else has happened as well.
The other thing that's
happened is imagine we have
a situation where the seeing
eye is not strong enough
to evoke a response and the
strong eye is not seeing.
So as a consequence the
activity in the cortex falls
and this is the condition required
to induce this metaplasticity.
So eventually what we see is as
the change in the rules of the game,
so this function will slide to the left,
and this will allow the recovery of
the formerly deprived, now seeing eye.
It can recover 'cause it's got
reasonably correlated
activity, it was very weak,
and now this weak activity
is enough to start to gain
a toehold and drive the synapses up.
So I mentioned that there are
issues with patch therapy.
It's not ideal and the
question is can we use
these principles of metaplasticity
to restore function without
resorting to patching?
Well there's good reason to
believe that that's the case.
First there have been a couple
of studies done by others
where they put animals
into complete darkness
after a period of monocular deprivation.
So literally one or two
weeks of complete darkness,
then the animals are
brought back into the light
with both eyes open and
what they've observed is
they can get a recovery of vision.
Could be quite dramatic.
But it does require weeks of darkness
and that darkness cannot be interrupted
even temporarily by light exposure.
So we wondered if we could do better again
based on what we knew about
this metaplasticity property.
So the experiment that we
did was to use an anesthetic
and inject both eyes with this anesthetic.
It's an anesthetic called tetrodotoxin.
But really any drug that would block
sodium dependent action
potentials would work.
So essentially what
we're doing is in essence
we're rebooting the visual system.
We are turning it off,
and then we're gonna let
it turn back on again.
So the rationale here is
that we put this tetrodotoxin
into the eyes and we block
all impulse activity.
This curve slides to the
left and this will promote
the recovery of the weak
input, so what happens?
Well I wouldn't be telling
you this if it didn't work,
(audience laughing)
works beautifully, works
amazingly, amazingly.
So this is work from mice here,
so I have to introduce a little bit.
Essentially the only thing that matters
is that the blue bars represent
the strength of one eye,
the eye on the opposite side of the head,
the contralateral eye, and
the yellow bar represents
the strength of the other
eye, the ipsilateral eye.
So if you don't do anything to a mouse,
the heights of these bars wax and wane,
but they don't change too much.
If you monocularly deprive
a mouse, as we've done here,
it goes from here where
we close the blue eye,
so this response is depressed,
and it stays depressed.
Okay, it never recovers spontaneously.
But if we follow that
monocular deprivation
with this bilateral
injection of tetrodotoxin
to turn the eyes off,
when the TTX wears off,
we see a rapid recovery of
vision to the deprived eye.
So this is the magic treatment
that we did in the kittens.
So in these animals tetrodotoxin
was injected bilaterally.
In this case we did two
injections into both eyes
because we didn't want
to take any chances,
but you can see it's just a really
remarkable recovery of sight.
And then this is an
example of one experiment
where initially we failed, we
failed because the injections
weren't successful and they didn't block
the pupillary light reflex so we knew
we hadn't blocked impulse activity.
We were disappointed,
animal kept maturing,
we wondered what we were gonna do with it,
we said ah, let's try it again.
So we tried it again and now
at the ripe old age of five months,
a single injection of TTX and again we saw
this great recovery, so
we're excited about that
because it's a brief
manipulation, even very late.
Just to compare, this is five
months of age or 20 weeks,
and you can see that's way beyond
what's possible with reverse occlusion.
So just to wrap up, we're
seeing recovery at older ages
than is possible with reverse occlusion.
Recovery is very rapid, occurs
over the course of a week,
it's 100% complete, and the
recovery of the weak eye
does not come at the
expense of the strong eye.
So of course what we wanna
know now is precisely
how did this retinal activation work,
and can we actually
translate this knowledge
into better therapies for human amblyopia?
And with that, just thank the people
who did all the work
and our funding sources.
(audience applauding)
- I am gonna talk today about identifying
the genetic underpinning of
autism spectrum disorders.
And then really wanna talk about that
as really the foundation
for beginning to understand
not only the biology of these disorders
but also something about
this complex interplay
of environment and biology
that you've been hearing about
throughout much of the day today.
I'm gonna start by just showing
a video of a child with autism.
Don't worry about the sound,
in fact it's very hard to hear,
but not having the sound
hopefully also makes a point.
You don't need clinical
training, I don't think,
to be able to identify really
what is the sine qua non
of the diagnosis of autism which
is a fundamental impairment
in reciprocal social communication,
so I think you can tell
that this is a young man
who is certainly not typically
developed in that regard,
in a moment he'll sit down and
start using a picture board
to communicate and has very
little useful language,
which is also a hallmark of those
social communication
deficits that is particularly
prevalent in more severe cases of autism.
Also at the beginning you saw,
I believe that he flapped his hands,
and the second domain for
the diagnosis is those kinds
of repetitive behaviors are
highly restricted interest.
So understanding the
genetics of this syndrome
despite the fact that we've
known for several decades
that autism does run in families,
has been extremely difficult,
we spent much the early part
of my career spending more time arguing
about why we couldn't get the same answer,
than we did in being able
to lay a strong foundation
for understanding our
biology of the disorder.
Wanna talk to you about the
strategy that my lab chose
to pursue and a number
of other labs as well,
which was understanding that
there was this very complex
set of levels of analysis
potentially to try to address
from molecule all the
way to complex behavior,
that our thought was that
if there was a possibility
that we could go from the complex behavior
directly to the molecule needed
to get us directly to DNA,
that that could be
valuable and the foundation
and then to pull on that
thread to be able to get
to more and more complex
levels of analysis
and really the whole idea behind this,
I don't think I could have had a day
that had a better set up for laying out
why this was a hypothesis
but the notion if we could
understand the detailed biology of autism
and other neurodevelopmental disorders
that this could give us
the kind of opportunities
that you've heard about today
with regard to amblyopia
and neurodegenerative
disorders, et cetera.
So there are many reasons
why we thought that this
might be a reasonable strategy among them
is that in some ways we had
the sense that this was really
the simplest approach to try to begin
to understand something
as complex as autism,
not a trivial undertaking
to try to find which
individual changes among
three billion bases in
the human genome present in every cell
that has a nucleus, in the nucleus.
But orders of magnitude
less complex in my view,
when I was starting my lab,
than a hundred billion neurons
that make up the human
central nervous system
and orders of magnitude still less complex
than trying to understand the
hundred trillion connections,
and you've heard a lot
about synapses today.
So we decided to take this approach,
you could call it really
a reductionist approach
to trying to, as I said,
get at the simplest part
of the problem and then move forward.
We did that starting about
10 years ago by focusing
on something called de novo mutation.
So when people think about genetics,
they often think about that as synonymous
with the transmission of genetic risk
from one generation to the other
from grandparents to parents to children.
But it's also the case that a small amount
of genetic variation is introduced
into the genome in each generation.
So there is quite a bit of
variation in the human genome,
if you turn to your left or your right,
you are 99% identical to the
person sitting next to you,
the level of your genome, so
I hope you got a good seat.
(audience laughing)
I enjoy mine.
But within that so even
though it's about 1%,
that's still 30 million
differences that you have
between you and the person
sitting next to you.
We were interested in de novo mutation
for several reasons so the
first is that if a de novo
of a new mutation which is
introduced at a low rate
into the genome at every
generation is connected
with something like a
neurodevelopmental disorder
to the extent that it has a
significant effect over time,
it will be eliminated from the
genome by natural selection.
But for de novo mutation,
natural selection has
very little time to act.
So unless the mutation is
lethal in the generation
in which it's present, you
can have genetic variations,
mutations that have very
large biological effects
and still if you can
find a de novo mutation,
you're able then to be able to
use that as a starting point.
And if you're interested in genetics
as a way to understand neurobiology,
starting with something that
has many, many fold increase
in risk versus a small
percentage increase in risk,
seemed like a start strategy.
This also comported with
the clinical observation for
many years that many families
come to clinical attention,
I'm a child psychologist
and can tell you that
it was observations in our clinic as well,
that a substantial portion come in
where there doesn't appear to
be any strong family history
suggesting that those
families in particular
might have been vulnerable to
the spontaneous new mutations,
de novo mutations contributing
to their disorder.
And then there were two key
papers in 2007 and 2008,
I think the most relevant one
and truly a seminal paper was,
I believe the author was Jonathan Sebat,
who's a professor here at UCSD,
showing that de novo
mutations and fine chromosomal
structure were much more
frequent in kids with autism
if they came from a family
without a family history
than any other group
that they compared to.
We then got very lucky
and we're able to study
a group of kids in the
Simons Simplex Collection
that was designed to
try to help us promote
these kinds of mutations
and this diagram shows
really the experimental design
which is to find families
that look essentially
like they've been hit
by a bolt of lightening where the blue
represents unaffected and red affected,
so to have unaffected parents,
and if there were siblings,
to have them be unaffected as well,
and only be able to have
a single affected member
in the family in order
to be able to participate
in this cohort and then
what we were able to do then
is to take a look and compare
the parents to the children,
and anything that was
present in the children
that was not present in the parents
was either a mistake
or a de novo mutation.
And the second thing that
we were able to do then
is to compare affected children
to their unaffected siblings.
So a beautifully controlled
experiment that allows us
to ask the same question again that
Jonathan Sebat and Mike Wigler asked.
I want to give you two
other senses about why
de novo mutation can be so powerful
to the extent that it
contributes to disease.
The first is that I've already told you,
that there are about
30 million differences
between you and the person
sitting next to you,
so you can think about that as
a forest of genetic variation
and in fact with de novo mutation,
I love this picture because
it really represents about one
de novo mutation per
generation in the human genome.
So out of, in the section of
that that codes for genes,
so it gives you very strong
signal and noise properties,
you can really identify where that is
and you're counting at very
low numbers, and since I,
like Jay apparently, am
mathematically challenged,
counting to one is something that
we've been able to do in the laboratory.
(audience laughing)
Now the second thing is
that this is a large area,
this forest, and we have very few events,
so we could also leverage a
approach to statistical analysis
that allowed us really
just to ask the question
if we saw de novo mutations,
particular spot in the genome,
if we looked at an unrelated child,
could we see lightning striking twice?
So we put those two things together,
this good signal to noise
ration and this idea
of recurrence of these very
rare spontaneous events
in order to identify
genes contributing to ASD.
One of the first findings
that we published in 2011,
first replicated, Jonathan
Sebat and Mike Wigler had done,
with about 10 times the sample size,
which was an enormous relief, I imagine,
to the entire field given
that psychiatric genetics
had spent many years, as I said,
arguing with each other about
why we could not replicate,
so replication was a pop the cork moment.
But this finding in particular
in addition to that,
we were able to identify a
new, small region of the genome
contributing to ASD,
autism spectrum disorders,
and that was on chromosome seven.
And we found that if you had an extra copy
of the small number of genes
within this chromosomal region,
there are about 25 that reside there,
that you would have
classically defined autism,
and look very much like the child
that I showed you in the first video.
We also knew though that
there was another syndrome
that had previously been
described that was the consequence
of the loss of exactly the same gene,
so autism, there were additional copies,
and in this case there was a loss.
And I'm gonna show you another
video, here we do need sound.
- Hello buddy, how are you?
- I really wanted to see you.
- Oh, thank you, thank you.
- What's your favorite color
and what's your favorite TV show?
- [Narrator] Kids love to ask questions.
But not as much as these kids.
- My favorite color is blue.
(gasping)
I have met Barney the dinosaur.
(kids cheering)
- Where do you live?
- I live in New York City.
- [Boy] Do you have any sons or daughters?
- I do.
- Wow.
- I have two daughters and a son.
- [Narrator] And kids
love to make friends,
but not like these kids.
- [Boy] What nationality are you?
- Italian.
- [Boy] How old are you, buddy?
- So that is Williams syndrome.
A fascinating syndrome, could
spend the rest of the talk
here and probably several
others telling you
about how interesting that syndrome is,
but for the sake of this talk,
what I wanted to point out
is that again, you don't
need any clinical training
to see the profound
differences in interest
in social relations in
affiliation in this group of kids
versus the example that I
gave you of the first child
where the core deficit is a failure
of that reciprocal social communication.
So when you think about this,
so what I relayed out was
a hypothesis that you could go from
a complex behavioral phenotype,
go to the genome, and
then work your way back.
I think it would be reasonable
to be skeptical about,
that's a long distance between
a change in a small section
of the genome going through
molecules, cells, circuits,
behavior, and brain,
and invoking additional
things like environment and experience.
But this gave us a shot
in the arm about thinking
at least in some cases
this was a viable approach
because if you do the thought experiment,
if we could understand what
it was about these 25 genes
in the genome or the subset
of them that were contributing
to this difference that
you're looking at a powerful
(mumbling) of something as
complex as social affiliation.
As genomic tools advance, we're
able to move from looking at
segments of the genome, this
fine structure of chromosomes,
to doing the same experiments
again at much higher
resolution now to the single
letter of the genetic code
of all the genes of the
genome simultaneously.
And what you're looking at
here is a summary from 2015,
it's giving you now a picture
of all of the reliable genes
that we've been able to
identify that are contributing
to autism spectrum disorders, again,
with a substantial portion of these
conferring many, many
fold increases in risk.
They're individually rare in people
but in the person that they exist,
they are having profound
biological effects.
This is Stephan Sanders on the right,
he was a post doc at the time of the lab,
now a junior faculty at
UCSF, a brilliant young guy
who led several of the studies that led to
this summary statement that
includes not only our work
but work with laboratories
around the world
that have replicated both the
initial observations around
de novo mutations as well as
specific genes shown here.
So where does that leave us?
Now we've gone from a situation where,
at least for the first
15 years of my career,
it was like wandering in the desert,
I would have given
anything to find a single
gene associated with
autism spectrum disorder
that I felt I knew
reliably and now we have
a series of genes, there are
60 genes that were represented
in that picture as well as a
number of chromosomal segments.
So and that reflects only
a small number of the genes
that we now predict are going to be found
that can contribute to
autism spectrum disorders.
This is a version of a diagram, actually,
that we put together with Pat Levitt
before the advances that
I've described for you,
because they have been fairly recent.
And at the time was aspirational
but it's turned out to be
actually I think a pretty
good representation
of where we are and where we're heading.
So the diagram is supposed
to show the same kind
of progression where we have genes,
and there are many of them,
distributed across the genome,
that then underlie some biology.
And we hypothesized
before we found the genes
that they would not be
randomly associated,
but in fact would point us to
specific biological processes,
and that has turned out to be the case.
One of the strongest signals that we have
is that these mutations
preferentially target genes
that are involved in synaptic
formation and function.
There are other broad areas of biology,
but it's turned out, you've heard all day
about the importance of
synapses and it turns out
that they are quite
important for autism as well,
and somehow that's mediated
through the developing brain,
this is a picture of the
brain developing in a circle
from embryo all the
way to developed brain.
Just to remind you that
while we found some biology,
that that biology's being
expressed across development
in the brain and that we don't go
directly from genes to behavior.
And that we know that we're
now able to find genes
that dramatically increase
the risk for autism.
There's some additional complexities here
and one of them that we found
right off the bat is that
while we were finding genes
that were very reliably
associated with a dramatically
increased risk for autism,
our colleagues studying
intellectual disability,
epilepsy, and schizophrenia,
were finding some of
the exact same regions to the genome.
So this presents an important but I think
not only challenging but
optimistic kind of concept
because you've heard about this notion of
the potential plasticity
and what this tells us
is that even if you have a gene,
that it profoundly increases
the risk for autism,
that for some people you see
nothing for the first 15,
18 years of life, suggesting
that genes are not fate
even ones that carry large risk,
but somehow that all the
things that we're talking about
today could potentially be important
in determining how these
play out over time.
And this diagram shows at the bottom there
that there are a variety
of things that you could
hypothesize might be involved
in that, epigenetics,
involvement of the cellular
molecular environment,
other genetic variance
that have smaller effect
but help dictate how these
large genetic risks play out.
And potentially for
some individuals, luck,
but it does also open up this
notion of potential plasticity.
Something I also, Mark did a
beautiful job of laying out
the three hypotheses about the development
of neurodevelopmental disorders,
the pessimistic one
and the optimistic one,
and I think it's important
to keep that in mind,
particularly in autism,
something where there's a large
genetic complement and you'd see this
playing out in very early life.
It is also the case that
despite the fact that we are
not anywhere near satisfied with
the treatments that we're able to provide,
that kids do improve
with early intervention.
I think pointing to the
fact that genes are not fate
and that beginning to use
this body of knowledge
to understand how this genetic
risk plays out over time,
leading either to
multiple disorders or not,
or improving over time is
something that is quite important.
So I think where we end is
that, at this talk at least,
but hopefully not in the field,
is that on the left side of the diagram,
that we now have made significant progress
not only in understanding
the genetic substrate
but beginning to define what
the biological processes are
and many labs using the kinds
of tools that you heard about
all day today are now
beginning to place that
in a developmental context to understand
the timing of the genetic risk
and how that's playing out.
I think that leads to, we hope,
the substrate to begin
to attack these problems
in the way that you've
been hearing all day,
that we're attacking
other complex disorders
where the underlying
biology has been more clear
than it's been for complex
neuropsychiatric disorders.
And so I wanna end by,
as with everyone else,
I get to stand up and give
the talk and a list of people
who did all the heavy
lifting and particularly want
to point to Stephan Sanders
for the remarkable work
that he's done on gene discovery
and my collaborators
really around the country
who have made this work possible.
And I can't end without also
thanking not only the funders
but most importantly the
families that contributed
to the Simons Simplex Collection
that we were able to study
so productively for the last decade or so.
Thanks very much.
(audience applauding)
(bright music)